tenemos 14 x 4 sobre menos 3 x 2 igual a
8 y te doy un momento para que
consideres si la puede resolver tú solo
a simple vista esta no parece una
ecuación lineal pues tenemos una
expresión que se encuentra sobre otra
expresión pero como veremos esto lo
vamos a simplificar para que quede
claramente como una ecuación línea así
es que lo primero que voy a hacer a mí
no me gusta esta expresión menos 3x
menos 2 el denominador me estresa así es
que voy a multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por menos 3 x menos 2
multiplicó el lado izquierdo por menos 3
x menos 2 y el lado derecho por menos 3
x menos 2 que ganamos bueno del lado
izquierdo tenemos menos 3 x 2 sobre
menos 3 x menos dos podemos simplificar
esto nos da 1 así es que del lado
izquierdo tan sólo nos queda 14 x + 4 y
del lado derecho que nos queda
nos queda 8 x menos 3 x 2 vamos a
realizar el producto 8 x menos 3 x 8 x
menos 3 x es menos 24 x 8 x menos 2 es
igual a menos 16 y ahí la tenemos ya le
hemos simplificado para que se vea como
una ecuación lineal típica tenemos la
variable ambos lados así es que
continuemos simplificando así es que lo
que voy a hacer ahora es agrupar los
términos en x del lado izquierdo así es
que para eliminar este menos 24 x del
lado derecho lo más fácil es sumar 24 x
sumó 24 x pero para que no se altere la
ecuación tengo que sumar también 24 x
del lado izquierdo sumado 24 x entonces
del lado izquierdo y que tenemos ahora
del lado izquierdo
nos queda 14 x más 24 x es 38 x más 4 38
x + 4 del lado derecho se cancelan estos
menos 24 x 24 x era lo que queríamos y
nos queda tan solo
16 - 16 ahora para deshacernos de este 4
vamos a restar 4 a ambos lados de la
ecuación los restamos 4 el lado
izquierdo y restamos 4 el lado derecho y
que no resulta
del lado izquierdo tenemos cuatro y
menos cuatro se cancela nos queda tan
sólo 38 x y esto es igual a menos 16
menos 4 es igual a menos 20 finalmente
vamos a despejar x dividiendo entre 38
ambos lados dividimos entre 38 ambos
lados del lado izquierdo se cancela
38-38 nos queda tan solo x y del lado
derecho nos queda menos 20 sobre 38 y
esto podemos simplificarlo aún más
podemos sacar mitad arriba y mitad abajo
la mitad de menos 20 es menos 10 y la
mitad de 38 es 19 así es que x es igual
a menos 10 sobre 19 y ya hemos terminado
y te reto a que valide este resultado es
un número no muy atractivo pero lo que
tienes que hacer es tomar este número y
sustituirlo en la ecuación original y
verificar que efectivamente se cumple la
igualdad